Our first step is to substitue this value of r into the equation. Now we need
to work toward isolating t so I'm going to divide both side of the equation by
this coefficient out here, ten to the negative 12. That leaves us with 0.795
equals e to the negative t over 8223. Now what we need to do is get t out of
the exponent. So what do we need to do? Well, we need to take a log. Since e is
the base of our exponent here, our log should have the same base. That means we
need to take the natural log of both sides. On the left side, that's just going
to give us some number that we can calculate with a calculator. But, over here
something a little bit more interesting is happening. We have two inverse
operations that are going to cancel one another out. Leaving us with just the
exponent as the entire quantity on the side. I'll leave the left side as is for
now. So we have natural log of .795 is equal to negative t over 8223. Now it's
easy. All we need is a little bit of multiplication. We need to multiply both
sides by negative 8223. So that leaves us with t equals negative 8223 times the
natural log of 0.795. let's pull out our calculator to figure out what number
this is equal to. Using a calculator and rounding gives us a value of t of
about 1886. So this piece of parchment from the dead sea scrolls is about 1886
years old. Now, in a real situation, estimates are a bit better than this. They
are calibrated using, for example, tree rings to determine a slightly more
accurate amount of carbon-14 in the plant material at a given time. Still, it's
pretty awesome that we can even come up with any sort of estimate.